on va commencer par ton ami jean-michel
ouest jean michel c'est ton ami dans la
vie si ton ami sur le plateau oui et on
voulait démarrer ce soir avec
jean-michel parce que jean michel c'est
vrai que c'est quelqu'un de très pudique
c'est quelqu'un que vous aimez
énormément c'est kaka qui est dans
l'aventuré avec moi depuis le début
mais depuis dix ans bon mathieu je sais
que c'est devenu ton ami vraiment ton
ami proche tu penses que c'est un des
meilleurs amis ce n'est le meilleur
aujourd'hui william s'est vu hier soir
encore et il m'a appelé deux fois
aujourd'hui pour essayer de savoir ce
qu'il ya dans l'émission à craquer
surtout c'est pas que je n'ai pas craqué
ce que vous ne saviez pas ce qui a pu
passer devant mais il a craint il sera à
la hauteur exacte il est maître sans
filet et sans slip
alors je vous le dis pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de tpm pays nous
allons entendre le son de la voix d'une
personne très proche de jean michel jean
michel pour cette saint valentin
l'amour peut avoir toutes les formes
un amour passionnel
un amour fratricide présidera un amour
vous le reprenez pas que tu peux lui
parler sur la fée des dents et tu leur
prends pas ça peut être très précis doit
bien sûr c'est l'humain elle connard
suis là par les français en 2007 il a
touché du doigt
ouais c'est vrai mais c'est toi ce que
cela semble absolument c'est ce que
c'est mais tu as tu connaissais pas
l'émission quand même je veux c'est un
minimum quand même mon chou à bord
non mais franchement maintenant je sais
je sais je sais pas si ça va lui faire
plaisir ou pas ce qui va être très émue
et comme lui très pudique
la personne a tenu en cette journée
placée sous le signe de l'amour à vous
dire quelque chose de très très fort
c'est la première fois en dix ans on
vous fait cette surprise jean michel
regarde coup de pouce juste un message
vocal de cherrie adoré pour l'instant
valentin voilà c'est pour te dire que je
t'aime énormément énormément
tu essaies pourtant merci d'être en bas
pas aussi génial romain et moi on pour
témoigner de toujours être là pour nous
et voilà je changerai pas pour rien au
monde je te fais des millions de bisous
et je suis très fière de toi dernier
évidemment comme déjà demain et voilà je
t'aime très fort encore une fois et tu
me manque beaucoup
alors c'est votre fille mines a cappella
j'avais ma fille mila qu'à 19 ans voilà
et j'ai été très émue d'avoir si on
parlait elle dit me manque je la vois
quand même régulièrement j'ai déjà joué
avec elle il ya quelques jours mais
c'est vrai je la vois pas assez et c'est
un chez un peu de l'ancienne école c'est
vrai comme les enfants deviennent grands
comme mon fils qu'à 26 ans fils romain
j'ai un peu tendance alors laissé appelé
à laisser un peu voler leurs propres
ailes et je pense que c'est pas eu ce
que c'est parce qu'ils demandent les du
coup je me l'obs culpabiliser pour ça
mais j'arrive pas à être plus présent
bon j'en suis désolé dans sa partie pour
voir les traits sont vraies ce que vous
avez envie de lui répondre ce soir face
à la caméra l agrément l'étudiante en
médecine fait études en basse alors
comme ça avait commencé l'émission elle
avait 9 ans elle était en cm1 et
maintenant elle est en deuxième année de
médecine donc déjà je suis très fier
d'elle bon c'est pas grave sa voix grave
sa même souligner qu'elle a réussi le
concours de médecine c'est clinquant sa
mère constance que jean basset dans les
manches que celle qui est qu'il cac qui
l'a élevé de façon magnifique avec qui
lui a tout transmis des valeurs
exceptionnelles et c'est donc je suis le
moins comme tous les parents fiers de
fier de mes deux enfants
voilà mais je pense que ça ça sentiment
que beaucoup partagent et je les vois
pas assez
j'espère qu'ils en veulent pas trop
voilà je vais essayer d'être plus
présent c'est une résolution que je
prends là j'ai essayé d'être plus
présent ce que je les aime tellement
fort comme tous les parents ont
évidemment mais je ferai tout pour eux
mais voilà j'en fais certainement pas
assez donc je leur dis que je les aime
évidemment on aura tout à l'heure un
masque lover pour vous aussi jean michel
maton aura quelqu'un qui viendra en
surprise pour vous oui c'est votre
soirée
ce soir on a décidé de bien à tout
témoin sur sa fille bien sûr mais c'est
très mignon c'est qu'ils dînaient avec
elle tous les mercredis soirs ce soir là
c'était même pas la peine d'essayer de
nine avec jamie c'était réservé à sa
fille sa fille lui son bac mention très
bien campés j'ai joué je te jure son bac
mention très bien elle cartonne médecine
c'est un amour et je dois dire qu'on
peut tout reprocher à jean mi mai quand
sa fille est là plus rien n'existe c'est
très touchant
[Applaudissements]